1995 bruxelles à droite c'est moi lille
a un ça va
c'était le début des ennuis lui c'est
mon père omar c'est les filles font la
danse ou gymnases et eux c'est les
balances du quartier a que du noir
laborit et les ânes à bochum ça je
voulais danseuse mais mon père avait
deux projets pour moi je vais déchiré
vos passeports
je vais vous envoyer au bled chez ma
mère et vous allez faire d'humour sur le
cactus
mais quinze ans après j'étais toujours à
fond j'avais une idée en tête tenter ma
chance à paris
soit expliqué tu m'as mendier vers à
taïwan expliquent été souvent toi c'est
moi qui dicte les règles moment avec mon
père c'était toujours aussi compliqué
bon la nouvelle tulle je te paie
commande est là et grâce à fabrice je me
lançais dans le stand-up
j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas le choix à
ses besoins de ce tremplin je veux me
prouver que je suis capable
non papa tombé à on parle de toi qu'est
ce que tu veux toi je vais monter sur
scène bourg tribord histoire j'essaye a
failli rien quand je trouve horrible
pour pouvoir y est bon très rigide est
quelque chose de plus dernière fois
j'étais au feu rouge avait un mec qui se
curer le nez il croise trop ils sont
tous elle vient pour moi pour debarnot
c'est à dire là le français
si vous laissez le parcours initiatique
d'une jeune femme qui connaît
j'ai tout niké d'accord y'a personne
comme moi d'enghien
à part cette roma